in this video i'll be sharing with you
all seven tips that will help you with
fingering speed and control at the piano
all clips are taken directly from my
instagram if you're not following me
there already i invite you to do so
here are some ways to play a glissando
at the piano using the back of fingers
four three two
using the side of finger two
[Music]
just playing them with your fingers
using the top of your thumb
using the tips of your fingers
combination with your thumb and fingers
back of your pinky
so i promise you this is the fastest
fingering for a chromatic scale what
we're going to do is take e to e and
we're going to divide that up into three
different parts first part
one two three second one two three four
and third one two three four five and
back two
one
[Music]
and at the end there i just did five
five because why not
here's some quick advice for playing
chords and making sure all the notes
down at the same time rather than being
staggered
one way to practice it might be to
depress down the keys
maintain this exact position without
moving anything and then lift the entire
hand up
again don't change a thing
and then depress the keys again this
isn't perfect you'll probably move
around a little bit but it gives you an
idea of the type of position you're
going for another way is to simply stack
so start with one note then two
then three making sure you're always
getting all the notes at the same time
and then just adding one note
at a time an additional tip make sure
that you put attention to the tips of
your fingers so that you're not sloppy
in terms of
how you're positioning them
you can have flat or curved fingers but
don't have this sort of thing which i
see a lot sometimes i do it as well but
you have less control sometimes
when we're playing fast scales like this
i think it's really about micro
adjustments at the fingertips and also
at the wrist level
fingertips it's rather straightforward
if you're a little sloppy
you're going to be uneven when you're
pressing down the note but with the
wrist
there are tiny adjustments up and down
and sideways that happen to accommodate
what note is being played next
especially white to black case for
example here
i'm slightly moving up
and also here
of course it's not as apparent
when it's fast but it's a tiny tiny tiny
adjustment just to get a feel for it try
exaggerating the other way try playing
the scale with the fixed wrist position
high
see how hard that is and try it you know
even in the middle
or lower
it's really awkward
so in order to play chromatic double
thirds with ease think of it in two
parts the first part is one and two
[Music]
be mindful of e to f that is the most
difficult part
and think of a very small hop
you don't need to be pressing up and
down or
do any kind of inefficient motion
[Music]
just
keep it loose and then be mindful of the
top
the chromatic scale with three four and
five and when you combine it together
it should look something like that and
it should not be tense at all
especially from
here
to here
hope that helps
right hand thumb
right hand index finger
third finger
fifth
left hand thumb
index
third
pinky so as you can see this is rather
difficult for me still and i've been
working on it something that has helped
me quite a bit is to practice it in a
way where i'm singling out those notes
separately
maybe on every other offbeat
like that
and i'm basically training myself to
become familiar with the touch required
for a soft dynamic versus a louder one
in close proximity
so eventually
i can just play it all together
[Music]
so trills
something like this with
four notes a great way to practice it is
to keep it in tempo first of all and try
skipping notes
so of these four notes let's first skip
the first note
so only the last three
[Music]
try skipping the second note
[Music]
the third note
[Music]
and the fourth note
now try playing it all together
and that should help
[Music]